Hola gente buenas soy danche en director
del documental producido por yubili
accepted una historia que sigue a cuatro
estudiantes de la controvertida
preparatoria tm laundry y su búsqueda
para ser admitidos en una universidad de
élite hemos pasado cuatro años
preparando filmando y editando esta
película y estamos sin pacientes por
compartir con ustedes esta
extraordinaria historia contada por las
personas que la vivieron la película se
estrena el primero de julio en algunos
cines y puede encontrarse en Amazon y
Apple TV ahora disfruten del episodio
punto en común es un experimento social
que reúne a seres humanos con creencias
opuestas estas discusiones pueden
contener puntos de vista que son el
resultado de la desinformación recuerda
Buscar a los expertos Y ser crítico al
formarte una opinión por favor ve a la
humanidad de cada participante Y como
siempre fomentamos la empatía mi abuela
era profesora Universitaria cuando ella
y mi abuelo se graduaron de la
universidad y obtuvieron sus títulos de
maestría pudieron literalmente llevar
eso al banco como pago inicial de una
casa un universitario significaba un
ingreso garantizado
[Música]
tanto en común
da un paso adelante si estás de acuerdo
con la afirmación
mis padres esperaban que fuera a la
universidad
Aunque mi padre no fue a la universidad
pasó por un pequeño grado de asociado
pero lo principal era ser fotógrafo y
luego mi madre siendo de Jamaica tenía
una educación muy diferente siendo esa
su manera de salir de ese tipo de
ambiente de la pobreza ella siempre
quiso que yo fuera la escuela y ambos me
pusieron en una escuela privada para
prepararme mejor para la universidad así
que me iniciaron en el camino Tan pronto
como pudieron cuando crecí En realidad
ni siquiera me di cuenta de que había
una opción para no asistir a la
universidad
pensaba que esa parte era obligatoria
pero que podías graduarte o no también
era muy importante para mi abuela que
era profesora Universitaria y cuando
ella y mi abuelo se graduaron de la
universidad y obtuvieron sus títulos de
maestría pudieron literalmente llevar
eso al banco como pago inicial de una
casa en esa época un título
universitario significaba un ingreso
garantizado mi padre siempre fue el tipo
de persona que decía consigue tu título
no me importa en que sea así que siempre
sentí un poco de flexibilidad sobre lo
que quería hacer y por eso me tomé la
universidad comunitaria como un momento
para probar muchas cosas diferentes y
ver lo que me interesaba sin arruinarme
Mi nombre es Pam y estoy a favor de la
universidad lo principal que siento que
me perdí al ir primero a la universidad
comunitaria fue que no se me dio la
oportunidad de Buscar roles de liderazgo
en clubes o cosas de las que formaba
parte los estudiantes transferidos
tienen el estigma de no haber estado en
el campus el tiempo suficiente Me
encontré con mucha gente que hablaba del
síndrome del impostor o de la sensación
de que no eran lo suficientemente buenos
para estar en una universidad como la
ucla que no podían hacerlo tan bien como
la gente que había estado allí en los
cuatro años y sí Yo también sentí esa
sensación pueden los que no están de
acuerdo a acercarse
no había ninguna expectativa de que yo
fuera a la universidad Así que fue mi
decisión personal libre vi mucha pobreza
en mi comunidad en mi barrio Y cómo
puedo evitar esta situación como adulto
no había un plan b para mí así que fue
como si no lo hago voy a volver a mi
ciudad natal y voy a trabajar en una
fábrica o puedo hacerlo y ver qué pasa
el uso de la discriminación positiva por
parte de la universidad es problemático
bien
mi experiencia personal con la acción
afirmativa cuando fui a la p W me
eligieron más o menos en base a la
acción afirmativa había mucho marketing
no lleven a nuestra escuela la
discriminación positiva puede ser
problemática en el sentido de que cuando
estos estudiantes llegan al campus no
hay lugar para ellos sí es como bueno
tienen clubes o tienen otras personas en
las que pueden recurrir pero es más como
una vez que entras estás por documentado
debes resolverlo por ti y también Creo
que está siendo problemático en lo que
respecta a la sociedad porque hay muchos
blancos que dicen que la única razón por
la que esta persona entró a esta escuela
fue por eso especialmente las
instituciones privadas estas escuelas de
la liga ID ciertas personas asisten a
estas escuelas si no encajas en sus
estándares entonces puede ser excluido
de ese grupo mellamos aquí ya y estoy a
favor no ir a la universidad es un
privilegio
de quién seas y a quien conozcas creo
que las universidades apoyan a las
minorías dependiendo de donde seas en mi
caso soy de Baltimore había
oportunidades para las minorías es una
ciudad mayoritaria minoritaria si
estuviera en otro estado que fuera más
conservador o predominantemente blanco
creo que no habría tenido tantas
oportunidades
la meritocracia no puede existir en el
mismo lugar donde hay nepotismo y
herencias y todo eso pero siempre hay
algún tipo de acción para que la gente
entre las universidades personalmente
conozco a alguien que asistió a clases
en cierta Universidad de la liga Ivy con
un futuro presidente y era un estudiante
terrible pero por supuesto entró porque
era un legado y su familia donó un
edificio y así es como se llega a ser
presidente Así es Estados Unidos la
acción afirmativa es buena para dar una
oportunidad a gente que de otra manera
no la tendría creo que la intención es
buena y no se puede hablar de intención
cuando el sistema tiene el aspecto que
tiene También tenemos que tener en
cuenta el aspecto de las finanzas y el
dinero de las escuelas que ganan dinero
y cuando estamos hablando de la
intención sí puede un profesor que diga
o me alegro mucho de que estés aquí pero
eso no habla en nombre de toda la
universidad no habla En nombre del
Consejo la intención de estarnos una
oportunidad a las minorías o no Escuchar
quejas para aumentar su número aumenta
sus niveles de diversidad en realidad
pienso de otra manera creo que sí la
acción afirmativa En definitiva funciona
contra el nepotismo y siento que si
fuera por la acción afirmativa muchos
estudiantes negros no podrían ir a las
pwv Y entonces estoy de acuerdo en que
una vez que llegas allí hay una
dificultad para hacer un estudiante de
color en una institución
predominantemente blanca con esa
posición también era el otro lado el que
decía lo mismo decían no te dejaremos
entrar porque no encajarás Bien aquí en
la cultura Y esa es la forma que usaban
para impedir que la gente pueda ir no
diré que es mejor que me rechacen porque
no tienen los recursos sino que me dejen
llegar allí y me dejen descubrirlo por
mí mismo lugar de decirme que no
encajaré bien y eso es lo que permite la
discriminación positiva y también diré
que las mujeres blancas se benefician
mucho más que cualquier otro grupo
minoritario no se trata de que se
permita a los estudiantes de color
entrar en el campus sino de que se
permita las minorías un título no te
capacita para la mayoría de los trabajos
creo que lo que estamos viendo
actualmente en el mercado laboral es que
muchos empleadores están contratando por
experiencia
contratan para ver si sabes de lo que
estás hablando y ahí es donde creo que
las prácticas entran en juego y es
porque muchos estudiantes universitarios
hacen prácticas porque necesitan salir y
adquirir esa experiencia para que los
empleadores quieran contratarlos ningún
empleador te rechazará si dices Oye
tengo toda esta experiencia o sé cómo
hacer exactamente lo que estás
contratando pero no fui a la universidad
durante cuatro años el hecho de que eso
figure como una cualificación y un
requisito es como una especie de control
de acceso más que de quién va a ser el
mejor en el trabajo soy Michelle y estoy
en contra de la universidad Me convertí
en un anti Universitaria cuando me
gradué como la mejor estudiante de la
Escuela Secundaria y me di cuenta de que
continuar con la universidad sería una
condena por
mi madrina me regaló un libro llamado la
educación de los millonarios y ella no
había leído el libro por adelantado Así
que pensó que me iba a animar a invertir
en la universidad pero lo que el libro
hacía en realidad era explicar las
historias de mucha gente que se hizo
millonaria sin una educación formal
la mayoría de las empresas no se toman
el tiempo de leer ese currículum Lo
pasan por una máquina Si hablas bien y
conoces a ciertas personas para abrirte
el camino no necesitas realmente las
cualificaciones para hacer el trabajo la
gente que tiene las cualificaciones no
consigue el trabajo sí he estado
buscando trabajo en los últimos dos
meses empecé como una hoja de cálculo
donde ponía Cuántos de ellos piden x
cantidad de años de experiencia casi
todos ellos eran necesarios títulos
universitarios incluso conseguí como
tres o cuatro por cada 40 que solicite
soy de Miami y solía trabajar para el
condado y para eventos sociales y ahora
que me he mudado aquí me resulta muy
difícil hacer la transición hacia el
mismo campo porque le dijo a la gente Yo
solía organizar torneos de fútbol solía
organizar colectas de alimentos pero
como no tengo un título en marketing o
en coordinación de eventos o la gente
como has dicho dice necesitas un título
para entrar pero como no tengo ese
título ni siquiera me dejan entrar me
llamo Kenny y estoy a favor la
universidad era la universidad es muy
importante porque he tenido una larga
línea de familiares que han sido
educadores mi madre que falleció de
cáncer era profesora y cuando llegó a
este país el único sueño que tenía para
mí era ir a la universidad en las
primeras etapas de mi existencia a la
escuela sentí que era una carga muy dura
de llevar el hecho de no saber que
quiero hacer cuando vaya a la escuela
pero tengo que hacerlo porque son los
deseos de otra persona Pero al final
cuando empecé a crecer y a darme cuenta
de que tenía mis propias razones para ir
a la universidad de que además podía
cumplir el sueño de mi madre fue algo
que realmente me empujó a querer
continuar mi educación e ir a la escuela
la deuda de los préstamos estudiantiles
Debería ser perdonada
[Aplausos]
para mí es una locura que vayas durante
cuatro años y estés pagando cientos de
miles de dólares en deuda y que puede
que cumplas con todos los pagos y aún te
quede como más del doble por pagar un
plan de pago realmente popular que hemos
estado viendo en la universidad
deportivo comenzó a hacer esto se llama
de acuerdos de participación de los
ingresos Así que en vez de pagar por tu
título por adelantado si la universidad
realmente te ayuda a conseguir ese
trabajo empiezas a pagar un porcentaje
de tu salario en los años de estudio y
después de cinco o siete años el
porcentaje que pagues es estupendo y si
no y no estás haciendo mucho dinero
entonces la universidad realmente te
falló en ayudarte a conseguir esa
carrera Eso me gusta la responsabilidad
recae en la institución donde debe estar
no en el prestatario es muy fácil decir
bueno en los países nórdicos paga 5
dólares y obtienes tu título es fácil
pero aquí es diferente y conocido y lo
será a menos que ocurra algún gran
cambio pero no sé cuál es Cómo nos
dirigimos a los millennials que pasaron
por la universidad y han acumulado
millones en deudas Y cómo lo cambiamos
para que sea mejor para las generaciones
futuras creo que debería ser cancelado
solo por las pretensiones en las que los
préstamos fueron dados es literalmente
la definición de préstamo predatorio en
términos de dar miles de dólares a
alguien sin puntuación de crédito
cuando tienen esos préstamos y no
entienden que los intereses se acumulan
y luego seis meses después de que te
gradúes y tengas un trabajo no vas a
tener que empezar a pagarlos
Por qué qué está pasando mi desacuerdo
está en la forma en que se maneja
existe esta estafa en particular que
está muy extendida la gente se ha visto
envuelta en otras estafas y esas no se
perdonan inmediatamente entiendo que es
como es una situación diferente porque
de la cantidad de presión que se colocó
sobre ti y para entrar en esta estafa
incluso la presión gubernamental también
por lo que tienen cierta responsabilidad
en ella yo fui víctima de una de esas
estafas tomé algunos préstamos y luego
mi último año No tenía suficiente Y
entonces tomé un préstamo de 5000 y eso
fue lo peor lo que me ayudó a volver a
dar un paso adelante fue la palabra todo
algunas personas pueden haber pedido ese
préstamo al ir a la universidad y ahora
están ganando mucho dinero y pueden
permitirse devolverlo si alguien es
capaz de contribuir Por qué no lo haría
soy Daniel y en contra de la universidad
tomé un montón de clases diferentes
mientras estaba en la escuela de arte Y
obtuve supongo un conjunto más amplio de
habilidades que mi otro hermano Lo que
me pareció Injusto fue que nos costó lo
mismo ir a la universidad y sin embargo
yo obtuve un mejor rendimiento de mis
estudios que él y él continúa pagando la
misma cantidad que yo si alguien no está
seguro de su carrera vale la pena que se
endeude con miles de dólares cuando no
sabe que va a ser con su vida
los campos universitarios están
radicalizando a los jóvenes
al principio dudé porque interpretaba
que la universidad estaba influyendo en
la gente pero no creo que sea así Creo
que la gente que puede tener ciertas
creencias va a la universidad y las
difunde entre sus compañeros Así que en
ese sentido diría que los campos
universitarios están contribuyendo a
ellos cuando ves un titular y ves que
uno uno universidad está persiguiendo
esto siento que tiene mucho más daño
hacia la historia como si la escuela
está promoviendo este tipo de
comportamiento y siento que porque se
dan cuenta de que mucha gente está
recibiendo mucha atención por esas
escuelas específicas es como de acuerdo
vamos a darles más incentivos para
hacerlo porque está ayudando a que
nuestro nombre se conozca si no estás en
Estos espacios donde escuchas muchos
argumentos de cada lado es fácil decir
bueno eso no se aplica a mí así que
porque me importa creo que al estar en
un entorno universitario me veo obligada
a ver estas cosas y más expuesta de lo
que habría estado si no hubiera ido
cuando escuché la palabra radical la
puse en pausa Por un segundo porque creo
que tiene una conno negativa solo en los
medios de comunicación Así que creo que
cuando Oyes a la gente decir algo
radical piensas bueno Eso suena algo
malo siento que es educación como Si
estuvieran aprendiendo más sobre la
sociedad claro la historia del gobierno
en América y eso a veces te hace enfadar
y te hace querer hablar y convertirte en
un activista por un determinado tema o
posición
sin embargo en mi opinión no es
diferente de lo que los algoritmos están
perpetuando en las redes sociales Si
estás en Twitter vas a seguir a gente
que está dentro de tu espacio y vas a
ver ese tipo de contenido y creo que eso
está jugando un papel más importante en
la radicalización y haciendo más que en
el espacio político de lo que estamos
viendo en los campus universitarios yo
personalmente crecí en un hogar
cristiano conservador al crecer en esos
ambientes siento que la radicalización
realmente comienza en casa comienza con
tus padres que te dicen sobre la gente
creo que cuando llegamos a la
universidad estamos en un espacio más
libre para expresar estas opiniones e
incluso en las redes sociales también
hay un nivel de anonimato Así que la
gente se siente más cómoda compartiendo
ciertos puntos de vista Creo que estas
cosas empiezan en casa y se ven cuando
te haces mayor las universidades están
prioridad a ganar dinero en lugar de
ofrecer una educación de
todos están de acuerdo que bien
Cómo alguien que trabaja en una
universidad primero es un negocio y lo
veo de primera mano creo que para muchas
instituciones lo más importante es ganar
dinero así que tomarán ciertas
decisiones en términos de que nos
permitirá ganar más dinero que nos hace
quedar mejor como instituto en lugar de
que la preocupación principal sea la
atención al estudiante los profesores
que tuvo en la universidad comunitaria
no eran mis mejores ni peores que Los de
la ucla A veces mejores eran más amables
eran más accesibles el tamaño de las
clases era menor había más clases
disponibles cuando llegué a la ucla
pensé hay una clase y es solo a las 5 de
la tarde es en serio como se supone que
voy a hacer un horario sobre eso así que
me di cuenta de un montón de cosas
cuando llegué a la ucla como Esto no es
lo que pensaba las universidades en las
que me gradué se centraba mucho en los
estudiantes de primer año todo giraba en
torno a ellos traer más estudiantes de
primer año porque la tasa de graduación
Es muy baja además traen dinero ellos
estaban ahí todo el año y si se quedan
se quedan si no no cambiaron los
edificios de
para que solo ellos tengan alojamiento
se trata de la calidad de los
dormitorios por las decenas de miles de
dólares que pagas cómo tiene eso sentido
además cuando miras a una institución
pública Y ves los salarios en 90% de las
veces vas a ver que la persona mejor
pagada es un entrenador y eso te
mostrará A dónde va el dinero real y es
como millones de dólares más que
cualquier otra persona que trabaje allí
me llamo Casey estoy a favor de la
universidad fue una oportunidad para mí
definitivamente con la capacidad de
sacarme de la pobreza crecí en un hogar
monoparental criado por mi madre Creo
que la posibilidad de ir a la
universidad y obtener un título me
permitió conseguir trabajos mejor
pagados y pagar las deudas de mi madre
así como ser una mejor persona en mi
comunidad
el sistema de aceptación de la
universidad está amañado
fui a uno de esos eventos de la escuela
que estaba de moda solo para aprender
más sobre el proceso de admisión y mi
madre se encontró con uno de estos
conocidos de cuando estudiaba y él había
puesto a todos sus hijos en la escuela y
una de las cosas que nos dijo fue que la
escuela lo hizo súper competitivo para
entrar por lo que su tasa de aceptación
Parece ser del 8%, pero para todas esas
transferencias es mucho mucho más alto
Esa es la forma de entrar diría yo en la
mayoría de estas escuelas si no tienes
las calificaciones adecuadas O tal vez
no puedes pagar ese año hay puertas
traseras y Al escuchar eso asumo que hay
más puertas traseras allí la universidad
de mis sueños cuando estaba en la
Preparatoria era ir a Georgia Tech
empecé mi proceso de admisión en la
universidad de Virginia occidental y al
ir a visitar el consejero universitario
en el campus de Georgia Tech me dijeron
Esto es lo que tienes que hacer esto es
lo que tienes que conseguir y en tercer
año nos mudamos a Tennessee Y acabé
la admisión de georgiatech en Tennessee
y me rechazaron y se me rompió el
corazón porque había cumplido con todas
las estadísticas que ella me había dicho
que debía cumplir acabé Llamando a mi
consejera de admisiones en Georgia Tech
porque había desarrollado una relación
con ella y recuerdo que lloré con ella
en el auto y le dije qué pasó Y ella me
dijo directamente que si hubiera
aplicado desde Virginia occidental desde
mi escuela habría entrado me llamo mejak
y estoy en contra de la universidad
Cuando entré a la universidad por
primera vez pensé que había que tener un
título universitario para tener éxito y
montar tu propio negocio y conocí un
montón de personas que habían abandonado
a la universidad y tenían entre 18 y 23
años eso me abrió los ojos Porque eran
personas que habían recaudado millones
de dólares para crear sus propias
empresas y no tenían esa formación
Universitaria mi madre tiene una
maestría y Mi padre es médico Así que
para mí dar la vuelta y decir Oye yo
realmente no creo que necesito cuatro
años de universidad
que puedo salir y hacer cosas por mi
cuenta fue un gran choque cultural para
ellos
pienso en la universidad como lo que
dijimos en términos de ser un negocio y
creo que están amañados para ganar todo
el dinero posible el Instituto gana más
dinero cuando los estudiantes están
fuera del Estado Sabiendo lo que sabemos
sobre la aceptación en la universidad
qué les gustaría ver no hay manera de
que los que quieren ir a una universidad
puedan ir así que tienen que encontrar
alguna manera de evitarlo creo que tiene
que haber más transparencia en general
con las universidades los estudiantes
tienen que ser conscientes de lo que van
a estudiar en la universidad de quien
quieren aprender Creo que será
beneficioso que pueden aprender ellos
una vez que llegan allí soy kyle y estoy
en contra de la universidad Si pudiera
hacerlo todo de nuevo elegiría no ir a
la universidad Porque ha habido varios
puntos de referencia en los que puedo
pensar que también he progresado
creativamente que han ocurrido fuera del
aula en términos de experiencia o cosas
que he aprendido de la gente que trabaja
en la industria o también lecciones que
He descubierto sobre mí mismo
simplemente por estar sentado haciendo
el oficio que quiero hacer eso más o
menos no me lo enseñaron en las clases
que pensé que me enseñarían deberíamos
dejar de decirles a los niños que todos
deben ir a la universidad
sí creo que algunos niños Sí realmente
sobresalen en la escuela entonces sí
quieres animarlos pero siempre habrá un
niño que no tiene idea de lo que quiere
hacer y no se le debe presionar para que
vaya ni siquiera se le debería animar a
ir tiene que descubrir algo si sus
habilidades no son propicias para un
grado normal ir a la escuela de comercio
aprende un oficio y harás dinero creo
que tenemos que dejar de decir a todos
los niños que tienen que ir a la escuela
más bien decirles si no quieres ir a la
escuela Aquí tienes otras opciones Sí
más centrado en la carrera en la
profesión en especial en algunos de
nuestros casos cuando se espera que
vayamos a la universidad y a la gente no
le importa el título que tengas es una
bandera roja ya que necesita ser
intencional sobre las elecciones que
haces la universidad ya no es un
indicador de éxito futuro con internet y
con todo este acceso al conocimiento
puedes crear tu propio futuro fuera de
la universidad y creo que realmente es
bueno para ayudarte para avanzar a las
carreras como médico o abogado donde
necesitas una educación superior aparte
de eso creo que es mucho más barato y
tiene mucho más sentido para la gente
encontrar una escuela de oficios o ir a
su colegio comunitario local y
simplemente obtener las habilidades que
necesitan de modo que puedan empezar a
trabajar No creo que la universidad sea
para todos pero creo que la mayoría de
las veces cuando oímos conversaciones de
gente que dice deberías ir a la
universidad suele ser de gente que no ha
ido a una es como un consejo genérico en
términos de que deberías hacer algo con
tu vida es lo que tratan de decirte y
solo utilizan la universidad Porque creo
que sigue siendo un indicador de éxito
estadísticamente Es probable que ganes
como un millón de dólares más y así
terminamos la discusión
[Música]